what's going on you guys lord adage here
coming at you
with a let's play today we're going to
be playing death's door
what's this game called again it's yeah
it's called death store i've really
enjoyed what i've seen about this at
events and when i saw this i knew
for a fact i had to get my hands on it
so we're going to go ahead and play
through this game see exactly what's up
see how much of this game's going to be
good
as you can see we have started the the
campaign i started a little bit of it on
another profile i didn't really do a
whole
lot i got to some point where i was
talking to someone he closed down a door
that's as far as i went and i was like
you know what i'm really enjoying what
i've been playing so far
so let's go ahead and get this let's
play going and show you know the
viewership my reactions in certain parts
of the game
and how exactly my thoughts going going
through the game so
first off i want to say is that bus is
on nothing
as you can see it it was a
[Music]
a hole so it's kind of interesting that
you know i i get it but i feel like
some stuff like that it's important
you got to make sure that the you know
the
attention to detail man that bus should
not have been floating anywhere
so pretty much uh you know x is the
attack button
it looks like uh a's roll
[Music]
this is bo the the left trigger
and then we have the the roll itself and
this this is pretty much right here is
all as far as i've gotten
and uh this is when i turn it off so
well well well
those of you that's been watching the
iron lords podcast definitely
tune in on the channel that this is
going up on every sunday at 1 pm you'll
be able to
get down in this game see exactly how
much you guys have enjoying
uh we have a lot of commentary on there
i highly recommend you watch that
so let's get back onto the game though
look who showed up for work no warrants
for you
obviously you're a bird so birds eat
worms because only the early bird
catches never mind he's kind of doing a
joke there and he realized he wasn't
being that funny so he didn't do it
what you're lucky to actually have a
soul for you to reap
and not only just any so a giant so
think of the commission on that
i hope you haven't forgotten your
training stay on your talons
giant souls don't offer go up peacefully
dropping in the door for you now
so clearly here is the door that we will
be accessing this entire game
uh i don't know if it's this whole game
but uh your door will remain open until
you uh
until you return your designated soul
while your door is open you will be
immortal and your will age so get it
done quickly
so it seems like there's a little bit of
a uh you know a mechanic going on
age in this game that's cool
let's just go up here to this door see
what's up
i like how well the map looks
how it's got like all this dark feeling
sensation
so let's go into this this door i assume
this is a hub word and this door takes
you to wherever world you're at
so it does look like up here i was right
so let's look around here eight a row
i like when they do tutorials like this
because when they do tutorials like this
i don't feel like it's it's invasive i
don't feel like they're
they're forcing you to learn anything i
feel like you know they they want you to
be aware the mechanics in the game
but they're not forcing any kind of
tutorial down your
down your throat and i've always
respected stuff like that
this looks like right to shoot with the
bow
oh that's not it all right b
so let's keep going on here see what's
going up
let's keep moving keep on moving what's
this
oh it looks like all that did was open
up one two where the opening
door was oh man already a boss he did
say a big
soul the dramatic force spirit
let's fight it man let's fight it let's
see what he does
[Music]
all right so let's get rid of that i
don't want you guys seeing that no i
will not be
i will not be editing that out it ain't
happening
[Music]
so it's got four tentacles it looks like
knocks them randomly all at once
oh it looks like he's moving it
[Music]
oh what's he doing oh got a beyblade
going on here
hold up trying to learn how to shoot
this boat better
[Music]
hold up what's he doing
oh he's supporting himself i assume
oh it's a bomb hold up
maybe you have to take out the alarms
yeah here we go let's hit him a couple
more times too
[Music]
back to the tentacles
[Music]
[Music]
it's pretty simple ow
it's gonna look really bad if i die man
[Music]
look really bad if i die
it looks like he's almost dead
[Music]
don't want to get too close to him
there we go there's a little little
nerve wracking there for a minute
because i took all that damage in the
beginning of the game
so i was kind of like nervous if i was
going to get killed or not
what is that oh god
what was that
so that was the first boss
wasn't too difficult let's go out
go through this little door
i don't know where we are the law of
cemetery symmetry
cemetery i need to find something for
[Music]
health
something big up there i don't want to
mess with it i don't have a whole lot of
health
what's this
a life seed planting one of these in a
green pot will
yield soul fruit which can be consumed
to restore your health
all right so that's the health mechanic
now where is a green pot
let's find this green pot
where is this green part
where is this we gotta find this green
part man
so we have a an enemy here
oh there's a it looks like that might be
the green part
all right so this is going back to the
other place i assume
[Music]
is he dead yeah he's dead
i like the charge attack
are you coming let's go man there you go
wow
death i wonder what kind of mechanic
happens if you die
died already man being a complete
scrub already dead that's fine though
i was messing around a little bit too
much in the beginning
no more
we got this we might not
no
no plan c
i guess they're gonna make me eat it
maybe
i don't know how much that healed either
because i already had full health
oh god so it looks like it takes two
got this looks like here's some form of
a key
all right so let's go up
what's this over here
you collected a massive soul energy
somebody could be spitting the hall of
doors
oh so it's pretty much like the souls
that you get in like dark souls and
stuff like that where you find just
randomly bundles of souls laying around
so i could get down on that
all right so i have a key so let's
unlock this
a ladder let's go up the ladder
oh god what's going on
[Music]
that's a roly-poly
i like i like the the the aesthetics of
the
of this dark these gates they think
they're really
they're pretty cool
oh my god get him get him get him there
we go
oh what was that
wow i am scrubbing out man
all right i'm gonna stop trying to just
do nothing but charge moves let's not do
no more charge moves
the charge moves are getting me killed
man the charge moves are getting me
killed
let's do strategic charge moves
like that one because it seems like it
goes in with one hit that's the kind of
charge moves that we do up in here we do
strategic ones
yeah see it's a lot simpler just to
chase them people down
oh god
how many protect to kill them okay three
of that one of that
all right so let's go back up here round
two
i don't know how i got up there maybe i
didn't go that way no i went this way
oh here it is
this time i'm gonna be strategic
yeah see got to be strategic man
[Music]
gotcha takes three
one one
one
one one
takes a couple to hit him
oh there's a couple
there we go
yeah boy
gotcha i didn't even see what was coming
out of there
got to be quick on your feet
no
i ain't playing with you anymore
there we go simple man simple just gotta
play right man can't
can't be trying to to to do a power
swing every attack and that's what i was
trying to do and it got me killed
what is this
oh a reaper my time in this world is
over
i mean why is it over can't get in there
can i go down there no
there's some weird door shaped object
there a bunch of
coffins doesn't look like the coffins
can get hit
what do i do
should i hit him no oh yeah you do hit
him
unfortunately i am still alive sorry
baby if you try to hit me harder
[Music]
charge
still very much alive perhaps try
hitting me a bit of a run
it kind of reminds me of um the dude off
chakra shadows guys twice
where he taught you stuff beside the
shrine i don't know if some of you
remember that
i can't explain i've spent years
answering my name is stahab i am
the keeper of graves on the sacred
mountain and if you do try yourself
stringing somehow feel free
to try and kill me again so i guess he's
you'll probably end up killing him
sometime in the game i don't know when
uh let's go up here
see what's going on
the game has a very good soundtrack the
game looks really good
so far so good man so far so good
game pass greatness
what is this the way to the stranded
sailor
all right so there's something there
that i assume
the simple structure as twins a secret
lies within
so it says that as a twin so maybe
there's another one to those
it looks like this it looks like that
one's it
no different structure
[Music]
different structure
i like to fight some people on this
bridge
[Music]
got it
[Music]
what does this lead to
[Music]
oh
can you break this no
oh so this is like a regular enemy now
[Music]
okay
they're not too bad
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ow that hurt i felt that
gotcha what's over here
what are these
i don't know what that is some kind of
currency
[Music]
three
gotcha
just keep on moving
oh new enemy disappears
this stalk is at man
one one
oh
[Music]
gotta move a little bit
can't be a stationary target not good
for my health
[Music]
oh no i felt that man i felt that that
seemed like it hurt
oh so they shoot fire at you okay
[Music]
you ain't gonna hit me with that man
got one
[Music]
gotcha
[Music]
he's still alive
where are you going
oh my god they're coming at me hardcore
[Music]
got you
this fire man
gotta manage these creatures better
there we go quick work quick work
how do i get over there
all right so let's use this
where is this go to
all right so it looks like oh wait a
minute
that was a shortcut yeah that was a
shortcut
that doors should be over here i like
how the dead bodies just stay there
[Music]
i need this thank you
let me move around here
go up these stairs where's that door
oh there it is
little crow do i sense a glut of soul
energy come here and you could trade in
those those to get an age and calm back
so we're probably gonna end it here come
back
right at this point talk to homeboy down
there
he's writing in some book i assume he's
gonna be
their version of um
their version of like all the the npcs
that's in the dark souls and the demon
souls that
you contribute to so we're going to
definitely tackle that next episode
but i definitely appreciate everyone
coming through here definitely watch the
iron lords podcast every sunday
at 1pm eastern and until next time
i'm out peace